worse in those kind of societies where i
can really appreciate here where even
though yes it's never there's never
going to be complete equality so even
though there are um
it can be really terrible for men but at
the same time i do feel like this is the
best of both worlds do you think do you
think women should be heavily questioned
though if they're accusing someone of
something that serious where they should
be questioned on everything it's not
saying like
you deserve it but it's maybe
questioning the person's credibility
i think on a personal one-to-one level
um
i wouldn't necessarily have any heavily
questioned like we're talking about the
law in terms of yeah if it's a public
thing and it's going to court yes i
think it's innocent until proven guilty
so um but if if someone came to you
personally i wouldn't go about oh are
you sure this happened i think you
should just take it on board and try and
um you know take it to the right
authorities
i think i think when you when you say
that you know
i understand what you're saying but
don't you think you you're saying it's
better this way because it suits you so
i've been in a situation where someone
said oh he's done this but then when you
question a bit you find out actually no
nothing none of that happened
and she just said that because she
didn't want to feel as though she was a
you know three or four or whatever right
so don't you think that what you're
saying
is is better is just a situation that
benefits you and actually in society
where we question people when they make
accusations where the consequences of
those
accusations being true are very
very deep consequences negative
consequences isn't it better that we
you know look into it and see okay is
this true yeah to answer your second
question yes it is better to obviously
investigate and i feel like that's where
this is just like a backlash obviously
like an overcorrection of the things
that went wrong in the past however
because i've like experienced both i
won't necessarily say it's better just
because i'm a woman obviously that is a
factor to it but i also feel like it's
just not um productive for society for
women to be like harassed constantly by
men like it just i've had even
situations where a bus driver has
followed me like in the bus with people
in the bus i don't doubt that i'm not
doing so i i don't doubt that nigerian
could be
their uncles can be different but like i
don't what i mean is you know the people
that question you when you come to them
and tell them yeah isn't it better to
live in a society where people are
questioned because the consequences are
that because even if it's just in
personal life like that's character
assassination
so men every day can have their
character assassinated around campus and
in their communities and the women
aren't questioned at all
yeah exactly like i mean if i was a
woman and some some a man went to court
for something he was accused for
something even if he was if he came out
innocent i would not be with him if i
was an employer i would not hire him
because you never know
that person's character and personality
but not personality
that person is pretty much rude for me
so um question
do women have a right to be afraid of
men when eighty percent of violent crime
is done by men
i think so sorry what's the question do
women have a right to be afraid of men
because eighty percent of violent crime
is done by men
i think they'd be smart to be um scared
of men because i know for a fact about
the daughter right now i i tell her be
careful when you're walking on the
streets for a random men you know i
think it's it's better better to be
you know safe than sorry um
but obviously most
it's when people say that they feel
unsafe feeling unsafe and actually being
unsafe for two different things because
men tend to be the ones that um
are the victims of violent crime the
most so it's a balance what about you
guys
i would say be aware
um
that
the stat is what it is but i wouldn't
say
like
every day oh as soon as you walk out
your door 80 of men are dangerous and
walk in that fear because you're not
going you're gonna assume every man is
going to
attack you or do something to you
because you have that stat like be aware
but still like
live your life and
act accordingly don't be stupid and
naive and go out at night and go down
a dark alleyway and put yourself into a
position for something to happen just
but just be aware that's what i would
say
okay yeah i think that um
we're creatures of routine so if you're
going through the same areas same
neighborhoods like going from work or
wherever it is that you're going
over time you're gonna feel safe i mean
you're not you know if you don't if
you're doing though keeping it simple in
that sense like even me
moving to the aki to get used to like
you know how like the street lights
don't light up the sidewalk like the
pavement
you know so i'll be walking in the
street because they're better lit
because i don't know who's like lurking
in the dark under so i think
we all should just put ourselves in
safer situations and we're less likely
to be you know worried male or female so
yeah i think the problem is like there's
not too much of a distinction between
what it is to be a man and what it is to
be a woman and so that has sort of like
erased women's fear because society is
just telling us like we're exactly the
same and we're not so i think that fear
is actually very beneficial for women
and um so you you do think that we
should be afraid of men like if to some
extent i'm just clarifying yes yes
because they're different okay yeah what
about you guys
i think um
i think it's a difference between men
and women because men
will always be afraid of other men
we may not fear men
but we recognize the threat
always so my job as a father of a
daughter is to teach her
that she needs to cultivate this type of
awareness it's not a fear
it's an awareness it's an awareness that
at any moment when i'm dealing with a
man
if things go sideways i could get very
physically damaged
and just accepting that and then
operating from that and and having the
mental health
in order to not allow it to turn into
paranoia
and keep it in
something that produces protection
self-protection and not like just
freaking out
yeah same i think they need to be aware
not fear
aware for sure but the thing is like
women menstrual can be the scariest
thing to a woman but they can also be
the um
what's the opposite of scary
fuzzy
yeah not scary protection yeah they can
protect women as well
um
and i wanted to ask did do your parents
ladies did your parents ever tell you to
fear men
no no no
no
okay so so just this follow-up question
how is that different than fearing
certain races because of statistical
data
damn
i don't necessarily think that's a bad
thing to be honest but that's just me so
so if we flip this conversation and
insert it as a race yeah
you would think that's fine i don't
necessarily think it's a bad thing but
okay
this is spicy i like it interesting i
think one can be racist
and or sexist and not be both
so i think it's possible to understand
the dangers of a male versus female and
not be racist
i also think that some people could say
do you mean sexist or
sorry sorry um so i also think that some
people could be worried about other
races having
relations with their women like as often
the argument that gets put out there
because of their build because of their
physique whatever
and
maybe there's a point to that i mean